in the era of Trump America is finally
going back to its traditional ways again
and anti-feminists women everywhere are
loving it this president has done so
much for women you March all you want
but don't forget about the millions of
American women who march into the voting
booth to elect Donald Trump yes Tommy
53% of my weight gal pals and I voted
for Trump but now a group of pro-choice
Democratic women are starting a
dangerous new trend took office hundreds
of thousands of women again took to the
streets now many are looking to turn the
energy of protest into actual power the
number of women Democrats challenging
Republican incumbents for House seats is
a 350 percent there is a pink wave
coming and the pink wave is dangerous in
2012 298 women ran for the House this
year that number is up to 436 like this
headline from conservative website red
state says we don't need more women in
Congress we need to keep Mogga intact
and save men's jobs I'm a professional
snowflake blower and Ally to men so I
headed to Texas to stop Lizzie Fletcher
and Gina Ortiz Jones to first-time
candidates trying to ride the pink wave
to Congress I do think the silver lining
of trumps election is that there are so
many women who are inspired to run for
office
I think Trump's great for women and I
like to say it over and over again on
television until people believe me he's
rolling back workplace protections he's
rolling back health-care protections I
don't want to see another picture of 13
men walking out of a back room in the
Senate deciding what's going to happen
for health care yeah president Trump
signed an anti-abortion bill surrounded
by his boys
Lizzie's jealous because men have been
getting so much done like last year
states enacted 63 new restrictions on
reproductive rights Wow
men and government are so efficient when
it comes to women's bodies behind every
great man is a great woman and behind
her is another man calling her fat I
want that that is who ran for president
I guess I got my dream even so the pink
wave is gaining momentum in another part
of our magas state San Antonio the last
time Texas sent a new woman to Congress
was over 20 years ago so we are
underrepresented and disproportionately
affected and that's why I think you're
seeing a real disconnect between the
people that are being represented and
that who are doing the representing is
that they just don't have the experience
they don't know what it's like to be on
reduced lunch they don't know what it's
like when your health insurance plan is
I hope you don't get sick this is your
first time did I see a candidate that's
right how does your husband feel about
that my husband does not exist my girl
my girlfriend is quite supportive oh so
you're still in college I'm a lesbian a
democratic woman lesbian that's running
for office who is highly qualified to do
the job yes and I am also of color okay
I don't know which one of those to be
most upset about right now oh my god
Gina is a progressive wet dream and she
wants to push America in the wrong
direction forward how had she gotten
this far I don't come from wealth
personally or professionally and so you
know having emily's list a stamp of
approval has been very helpful in
reaching out to a broader set of folks
that are interested in supporting
pro-choice women
emily's list wait I'd heard this before
I've got any support from Emily clip
of course it's the nefarious workings of
a deep state Democratic coven whatever
emily's list is it must be stopped
oh hello there yeah but you wish you had
better security outside huh guess what I
know who are yes I am the president of
Emily's last Stefanie shriyak you work
for Emily's list but your name is
Stephanie cotton her first lie
emily's list is a 30 year old
organization that is committed to
sitting down with women recruiting them
for office supporting them financially
and ensuring that women's voices are at
the tables when I'm hearing from you is
that you're discriminating against men
well men do control 80% of Congress only
and we have over five million women and
good men who are members of EMILY's List
supporting this work now that concerns
me because it seems like you're getting
this widespread support for this very
niche political cause it's about 52% of
the population why do you want half at
the pie everyone knows that when a woman
takes a smaller slice of the pie she
looks better women in this country have
had a tiny piece of the pie for a very
very long time and they've looked great
Stephanie wasn't budging but the
election is tomorrow I have to do
something if these women are running for
office as a response to Trump I'm gonna
get old white guys to run as a response
to these women that's why I created
Jordans list a list that helps older
whiter men figure out how to run for
office
because somebody has to and that
somebody is anyone interested in running
for office you know if you look kind of
like how Congress looks anybody
Dornan's let's join the Jordans list
have you ever thought of running broad
mister why not hey do you guys know any
old white guys who might want to run for
office I realized I wasn't looking in
the right places we need more men
distinguished men like you running for
office I'm just here to play bingo
dammit not even at bingo it looks like
this youthful feminist wave has a real
chance
[Music]